In this exercise, you're going to set up a
cron job to periodically update the announcement about the conferences
that are almost sold out. You've already written the function
to create the announcement, so pretty much all you're going
to need to do is to configure the cron job.
So, you configure cron jobs in cron.XML, and this is
an example for what cron.XML might look like; has a
top level cron entries element and then each cron job
is specified within a cron element. You must specify
the path, and this is the URL that's going to
run the task invoked by the cron job. You can
optionally specify a description, and you must specify a schedule.
The schedule indicates how often to run the task.
There's a variety of ways to set the schedule, but
you must strictly follow the syntax or the current job
won't run. I recommend checking the formats for the schedule.
The developer documentation does a really nice job
of describing the syntax for the schedule, and giving
examples. For example, you can specify it to go
every 12 hours. You can specify it to go
once a year, first Monday of, let's say December.
And then there's other ways of specifying it. Anyway,
I really recommend you take a look at the
develop documentation for the schedule. But do bear in
mind, although there's lots of flexibility in how you
specify the schedule, you actually do have to get
the syntax exactly right. So, you can't say every
one hour. You actually have to say every one
hours. The admin console on appspot for your application
has a cron jobs page that shows you what
cron jobs you've got running. I've got my cron
slash set announcement cron job running already, and it's scheduled
to go every one minute, and the last time
it ran it had a success. If you recall, the
set announcement function queries for all conferences that are almost
sold out. So if we look at the quota details,
you can see that my query ops number is going up. It'll
go up every minute. The other thing that's going to go up every minute is the
Datastore API calls. So let's see. So that's 162 and that's 143.
Let's refresh, see what happens. If I refresh the browser,
and you see that now my Datastore Query Ops has gone
up to 144, and my Datastore API Calls have gone
up to 163. So every minute these numbers are going to
go up. It's actually not a big deal because this
cron job doesn't do a whole lot, but if you have
a cron job that does a lot of Reads and Writes
to the Datastore, It is going to use up your quota.
Another thing that running a cron job every minute does
is that it means you're, it means you're app engine
application is always in use, so it never has any
idle time. Which, you know, if your application is in
constant use by users anyway, it goes viral, you're hugely
successful, not a problem. But when your developing and testing,
it does mean that if you keep your cron job
running frequently, it's going to keep your front end up, and you're
going to use up your instance hours. So you can
see here, I've already used 4.64 of my 28 instance
hours. Not a big deal, but it's something to
keep an eye on. Off shot load cron.xml two app
engine. It stays there until you overwrite it with
a new cron dot XML. So if you want to
disable your cron job, it's not good enough to just
delete cron.XML completely from your app and re-upload your app.
You actually have to send up a new cron.XML
with no cron entries. So just delete the cron
entries for the jobs that you want to delete
and reupload your cron.xml. And another thing you could do
is just specify the schedule so that it only
runs like once a year then you're not going to
have to worry about Quotro or anything, but you
know, why not just go ahead and delete it anyway